[Music]
okay so this is 31 Kujo numbers 4 to 6
now there's some slight variation in
hell the sections finish so from the
fall 31 ku BJ around from the Carter so
you'll notice there's slight changes
that happen
firstly to see the linking move from 3
to 4 and then we carry on with 4 to 6 so
in 2003 with basically here now to go to
link into that as I as I strike this
away here you go to proceed in blocks
turns over okay so this is basically the
setup for 4 for 6 now it's making it
more suitable for but frankly it closed
it off here so this is the start
position I have a hand this way around
his hands that way around I open up when
I open up he's thrust so thrust
I'm gonna go strike he's gonna follow me
up and then he's to then attempt to
strike my Jo away to the sides open up
through an attack like Jo comes out here
these focus very full I love that and if
we do any more flowing this would be one
move then he go come steps forward for
strike this comes around for strike to
the head
[Music]
you